est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france les cours et les violences
existait avant leur confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre les cta turler
d'eau de féminicide a plus que je dis
pas doublé mais bien monté forcément on
n'a pas encore tous les chiffres
officiels c'est très difficile gros
n'est jamais d amélie roy a finalement
c'est le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément dans les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux mois à 3
[Musique]
nouvelle journée de mobilisation pour
les sans papiers et contre les violences
policières en france quatre
manifestations autorisées à paris c'est
là à l'appel des gilet jaune pour le
pouvoir d'achat et contre la précarité a
été interdite pas d'accord non plus de
la préfecture pour la manifestation
demandée par la communauté tchétchène
d'europe après les violences à dijon
cette semaine
le lancement officiel de la campagne
présidentielle de novembre de donald
trump
aux etats unis un rendez-vous sous
tension ce soir au grand meeting est
organisé à tulsa en oklahoma
une ville symbole d'un des plus
importants lynchage d'afro-américains en
le président américain a déjà lancé un
avertissement au potentiel
protestataires dans cette ville
républicaine qui lui est largement
acquise
aucun trouble ne sera toléré le monde
entre dans une nouvelle phase dangereuse
c'est l'avertissement de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé 150 mille nouveaux
cas de co vide à l'échelle de la planète
avant-hier c'est un record sur une seule
journée depuis le début de l'épidémie
le brésil lui franchi le cap du million
de contamination
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi plusieurs
manifestations en france aujourd'hui
dont au moins quatre autorisés à paris
place de la nation un cortège est parti
pour réclamer la régularisation des
sans-papiers à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale des réfugiés
c'est la deuxième mobilisation pour les
migrants dans la capitale en moins de
deux semaines
une mobilisation à l'appel du collectif
la marche des solidarités elle les
manifestants qui sont arrivés place
stalingrad dans le 19e arrondissement
aux alentours de 18h voyez les
précisions sur place de notre reporter
pierre pissavy yvernault ils étaient
plusieurs milliers c'est d'après midi
avoir répondu à l'appel du collectif la
marche de solidarité pour la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers beaucoup de personnes sont
parties donc à 14 heures de la place de
la nation dans le 11e arrondissement
pour venir ici dans le 19e
arrondissement de la capitale du côté de
la place stalingrad
beaucoup de manifestants qui étaient
dans le cortège également pour la
fermeture des centres de rétention
administrative mais aussi pour le
logement pour tous nous avons rencontré
certains de ces manifestants je vous
propose d'en écouter quelques-uns
papier c'est difficile travail sans
papiers étaient potables regarder mais
si tu t'y pas s'il n'y a pas de papier
tu peux pas travailler on n'a pas de
salle et envie d'aller prendre sont
difficiles
péniblement c'est très difficile parce
que en france
quotidiennement en europe quand apparaît
paniqué pété pas facile mais par contre
tout ce qui nous est dit comme les
consignes nous avons suivi donc c'est
qu'elle nous on veut on veut que nous
régulariser tous les sans papiers parce
que c'est pas facile quand je suis
territoire tu peux pas travailler on est
là aujourd'hui pour réclamer un les
régularisation de tous les sans papiers
qui sont edward et france via les sites
qui sont là ils ont travaillé pendant
les compliments même si l'avant de
confinement elle ya des gens qui
travaillent c'est qu'on est plein de
monde qui travaille travaux noir aussi
aussi des substrats fait là y'a plein de
choses nous juste on est bien ici et
pour demander pour montrer le les
présidents ou avec les populations pour
qu'elles puissent nous aider pour que le
gouvernement ne règle en rien tout le
monde et nous avons rencontré cet après
midi des travailleurs qui travaillent de
tous les horizons que ce soit dans la
restauration dans les hôpitaux mais
aussi dans la livraison nous avons
rencontré en début d'après midi
c'est un livreur de chez friche qui une
entreprise qui elle livre des repas à
domicile
une entreprise qui a décidé début juin
de ne plus employer de travailleurs sans
papiers je vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet jérôme pineau responsable du
collectif un des livreurs autonome de
paris le problème c'est que comme on les
considère comme des travailleurs
indépendants des auto entrepreneurs
eh ben c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
vers eux quatre les régulariser que s'il
était salarié et donc leurs propos c'est
de dire on n'est pas des vrais
indépendant on devrait être salarié pour
simplifier la procédure
on est en est en contact avec frichti
alors freestyle disent qu'ils savaient
pas sauf que des messageries internes
donc d'ailleurs comme on compte
découvert le journal libération montré
qu'il savait très bien donc maintenant
leur but c'est d'essayer de dire on
savait pas on va les aider mais pour les
aider vraiment techniquement il faut
quand même qu'on leur montre qu'on n'est
pas qu'on est mobilisé pour voilà pour
que les choses aillent le plus vite
possible
une manifestation qui s'est déroulée
dans une très bonne ambiance amicale et
musicale encadré forcément également par
les forces de l'ordre qui étaient en
tête de ce cortège qui donnait le tempo
de ce cortège tout le monde est arrivé
ici place stalingrad à bon port à 18h
comme cela était prévu la dispersion est
en train de se faire actuellement
et à l'occasion de cette journée
mondiale des réfugiés le haut
commissariat des nations unies vient de
publier son rapport annuel
selon l'organisation 80 millions de
personnes ont été contraintes de fuir
leurs foyers l'an passé à cause de
guerres de conflits ou bien de
persécution cela représente 1 % de la
population mondiale regarder
[Musique]
poutou
et pour en parler nous sommes avec ziya
oloumi avocat au barreau de paris
bonsoir dit à oloumi merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france on a vu que cette
crise sanitaire avait rendu visible ces
personnes jusque là invisible en tout
cas des sans papiers qui ont travaillé
pendant le confinement en france qu'est
ce que cette crise selon vous révèle
deux de ces personnes qui n'ont pas de
papiers pour pour travailler que la pub
bonsoir d'abord d'abord que la plupart
de ces personnes travaillent déjà
donc c'est important de le dire puisque
souvent on les présente comme des
personnes qui ne travaillent pas donc ce
sont des personnes qui sont parfaitement
intégrés à la société française pour la
plupart donc ça c'est important de le
dire et la crise démontre simplement que
on a beau essayer d'arrêter ce flux est
bien les personnes sont là donc il faut
les traiter
il faut traiter justement légalement
soit ce sont des personnes qui peuvent
avoir des droits et bien il faut le
reconnaître ses droits la soie ce sont
des personnes qui doivent être éloigné
bien qu'ils soient éloignés c'est très
simple le droit et on a vu ces personnes
être en première ligne pendant le
confinement certaines ont travaillé dans
des livraisons dont le nom bien connu
d'une entreprise qui est en train de
licencier en ce moment enfin licenciés
c'est un bien grand mot puisque il n'y a
pas de l'égalité il ya des personnes
aussi qui ont trait qui travaillait dans
les hôtels auparavant c'est connu
qu'en est il de ces personnes dans
quelle situation se retrouve-t-elle
d'abord la première des choses c'est de
savoir que ces personnes on était aussi
en première ligne pendant le coït alors
que beaucoup ne travaillez pas à rester
chez eux parce que ces personnes non non
non précisément pas de protection et
donc sont obligés de travailler pour
essayer d'avoir de l'argent pour pouvoir
vivre décemment
donc ces personnes là qui on est et
qu'il y avait du liquide qui avait du
travail qui était indépendant par
exemple et bien laver ne pouvait
bénéficier d'aucune protection
donc c'était un élément important par et
pour les personnes qui travaillaient au
noir donc comme on dit sans contrat de
travail
là non plus il n'y a
pas de protection donc ces personnes se
sont retrouvés du jour au lendemain sans
travail donc sans ressources financières
d'ailleurs on a pu remarquer que le flot
de sommes d'argent envoyés à l'étranger
avaient baissé véritablement pendant ces
trois mois de deux copies dont ils ce
sont des sommes envoyées à leurs
familles cela concernerait 350 mille
personnes en france vous vous confirmer
ce chiffre
alors c'est difficile de le dire en fait
le chiffre serait de 350000 certains
parlent de 500 milles en fait le chiffre
qui permet de les connaître c'est plutôt
le l'aide médicale d'état les personnes
qui souscrivent à l'aide médicale d'état
qui est en fait prévu essentiellement
pour les personnes sans papiers et bien
à partir de là on a un chiffre mais si
les personnes ne sont pas déclarés s'il
ne demande même pas les médicale d'état
eh bien on en aurait plus et aujourd'hui
donc la plupart demandent la
régularisation temporaire peut-être
comme l'a fait le portugal ou l'italie
vous pensez que ce serait une bonne
mesure alors effectivement si vous
voulez il faut il faut simplifier les
choses
ces personnes sont là personne ne les
éloigne très bien trois cent cinquante
mille personnes à éloigner c'est
effectivement difficile en allant donc à
partir du moment où ils sont là beaucoup
ont d'ailleurs des droits c'est à dire
que sont peut être mariées à des
français ou ronds sont parents d'enfants
français se sont ils ont des droits et
d'autres qui n'ont pas entre dieux mais
ces droits là et bien on peut leur
reconnaître ce cette possibilité dedrick
de la réserve pendant un temps pour leur
permettre d'avoir des droits justement
pendant ce laps de temps et le
gouvernement que répondu on a entendu
edouard philippe
à l'époque du confinement dire qu'il n'y
aurait pas de régularisations temporaire
qu'en pensez vous alors si vous voulez
la politique de du gouvernement c'est
vraiment de la politique c'est pas du
prague du pragmatisme
on est en train de dire qu'on ne veut
pas pas parce que dans la population
vous avez à la fois une majorité de
personnes qui disent il faut les
régulariser puisqu'ils travaillent et
qu'ils ne présentent pas un danger pour
la société
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez des
familles politiques qui rejette cette
régularisation donc on est dans de
l'idéologie
et de la politique le gouvernement ne
fait pas de pragmatisme c'est de la
politique et de l'idéologie
que répondez vous à ceux qui disent que
ces personnes prennent le travail
d'autres personnes légalement installés
sur le territoire bien écoutez c'est
très simple tous ceux qui sont
praticiens savent pertinemment que la
plupart de ces personnes travaillent
dans des conditions très difficiles pour
des sommes dérisoires et donc font le
travail que beaucoup de français ne sont
pas et pour cause ce sont des travaux
sont qualifiés et donc la france
heureusement a évolué et les français
aspirent à d'autres d'autres métiers
donc c'est pousser c'est un faux
problème et et que faire de ces
entreprises dont l'entreprise frichti
qui en a employé beaucoup qui
aujourd'hui les met à la porte
que faire faut-il verbaliser et
poursuivre en tout cas ces entreprises
qui embauchent ces personnes le droit à
son mot à dire effectivement ces
entreprises sont parfaitement au courant
de la situation
effectivement et on sait très bien que
beaucoup de français ne veulent pas
travailler ou sont beaucoup de mal à
travailler dans des conditions de ce
type en étant entre guillemets
indépendants et bien ces personnes là
doivent être traités de la même façon
c'est-à-dire il faut poursuivre les
entreprises qui s'adonnent au travail au
noir mais en fait si vous voulez
poursuites dont vous parlez c'est soit
ce sont soit les personnes salariées si
on veut entre guillemets ou qui ont
travaillé avec ces entreprises qui
double qui devrait poursuivre pour
requalifier leur contrat en disant que
ce sont des contrats de travail et dans
ce cas là effectivement il ya une
procédure spécifique soit effectivement
si le gouvernement a envie de les
poursuivre pénalement
et bien ça c'est un autre débat mais ça
dépend exact à mon sens ça dépend du
parquet de l'action que le procureur de
la république par exemple a envie de
faire il y a les entre oui pardon vous
êtes avocat est ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
procédures entamées de ce type ou pas
j'imagine que c'est compliqué aux siens
de pouvoir avoir un avocat pour entamer
ce genre de procédure oui effectivement
sur les ailes nous sommes dans une
société où la plupart du temps pour ça
que je vous propose est d'ailleurs que
la plus simple c'était de les
régulariser même temporairement et que
l'on souhaite effectivement on retire le
titre iront aussi effectivement on se
rend compte que la personne n'a pas de
n'a pas de droit pourquoi pas mais ça
simplifie les choses si on veut une
société de droit ou de contentieux
effectivement tout cela c'est possible
on peut aller au contentieux mais je
pense que aucun ni le parquet ni les
tribunes on a envie d'avoir une ne
l'arrivée de 350000 procédure c'est
évident il faut être logique pragmatique
maintenant effectivement c'est possible
d'organiser tout cela c'est parfaitement
possible de réclamer des droits
aujourd'hui nous avons la situation de
personnes qui travaillent en france il
devrait avoir des droits ils ne peuvent
pas toucher il faut bien le savoir le
chômage ni rien du tout même s'ils ont
cotisé
même quand ils sont déclarés qui
travaillent pas au noir ces personnes ne
peut pas toucher le chômage donc c'est
cette somme qui reste qu'elle peut pas
ça participe à la l'économie nationale
donc 350 mille personnes imaginez
simplement les personnes qui prennent du
pain des baguettes toute la journée vous
x par le nombre que vous voyez que c'est
de ce sont des personnes qui contribue
effectivement à l'activité et ils
prennent entre 2 mai donc la place des
français
la place que en tout cas les personnes
qui sont la population française ne veut
pas occupé merci beaucoup zhiyao louis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france autre manifestation autorisée par
la préfecture de police aujourd'hui une
mobilisation contre les violences
policières et en particulier pour lamine
dieng un jeune franco sénégalais de 25
ans il est décédé en 2007 lors d'une
interpellation de police on a appris en
début de semaine par la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme que l'état
français allait verser 145 1000 euros
aux proches de la victime afin de solder
toutes poursuites dans cette affaire
voyez les précisions de notre reporter
sur place thomas bonnin une longue
marche pour rendre hommage à lamine
dieng 13 ans après le décès de ce jeune
homme de 25 ans dans le 20e
arrondissement l'ordre
une interpellation par la police
treizième année dommage pour lamine
dieng et une manifestation plus générale
sur les violences policières d'autres
familles endeuillées était également
présente au côté de la famille de ce
jeune homme de 25 ans je propose
d'écouter d'ailleurs la soeur de lamine
dieng ramata james tomic roadsync à
l'auberge la france a accepté de verser
les indemnités que la cour avait fixé et
donc nous de notre côté
sur conseils de nos avocats nous avons
aussi accepté donc ses règlements alors
pourquoi ce choix parce que c'est un
aveu de culpabilité est l'aveu de
culpabilité bien pour moi c'est encore
plus fort que la condamnation est donc
pas là pour un résultat identique
on ne voulait pas encore comment dit on
a passé trois ans nous procéderons cinq
ans nos procédures pour aboutir sur le
même résultat
donc c'est pour cela que nous avons
accepté et donc la décision et public on
trouve l'arrêt sur la côte sur le site
de la cod h et nous nous sommes libres
de communiquer sur ces arrêts donc voilà
ils n'ont pas acheté notre silence
bien au contraire plusieurs centaines de
personnes étaient réunies donc pour
marcher dans les rues de paris et faire
entendre des revendications notamment
celle de mettre fin à certaines
techniques employées par les forces de
l'ordre lors des interpellations pense
notamment à cette clé d'étranglement qui
fait polémique depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines
beaucoup de personnes donc rassembler et
au milieu de ce cortège il y avait aussi
des gelées jaunes qui avaient de quoi
témoigné en ce qui concerne les
violences policières on a notamment vu
jérôme monde au sein de ce cortège
d'autres actions sont à attendre
désormais puisque vous savez depuis
plusieurs semaines les manifestations
contre les violences policières se
tiennent assez régulièrement dans les
rues de la capitale et des policiers
toujours mobilisés eux aussi est en
colère d'être rendu responsable de tous
les maux de la société ils en veulent
surtout à leur ministre christophe
castaner et demandent toujours à être
reçu par emmanuel macron écouter
alexandre langlois secrétaire général du
syndicat de police vigie tout ce qu'on
avait dit c'est qu'on n'était pas
d'accord sur le mode horde se dire que
le ministre on est d'accord qu'il fasse
le nettoyage justement pour les
minorités de policier raciste donc
l'impression que certains policiers
manifestent dans les rues pour dire on
veut continuer à être raciste on veut
continuer à étrangler les gens
pense que le message est complètement
brouillé effectivement il ya de la
colère chez les policiers ce qu'il ya un
taux de suicide très important de quoi
l'être quand tu te suicider on doit être
à plus de 15 depuis le début de l'année
encore 59 l'année dernière les a
toujours été la crise sanitaire qui n'a
pas été digéré par de nombreux policiers
tellement été mal gérée au niveau de nos
effectifs
donc il ya beaucoup de sujets de
mécontentement est dommage que la petite
goutte d'eau explosent à cause de
paroles malencontreuses du ministre
disant avec des soupçons avérés qui en
plus ne veut rien dire en français de
toute façon et après dernière chose en
plus des syndicats appellent à des
manifestations illégales et ce qui remet
en cause la crédibilité nos collègues
quand ils doivent interdire une
manifestation illégale
quelle crédibilité ont-ils quant à eux
mêmes se font la même chose quelques
jours auparavant
donc en fait nous sommes sur un mélange
de toutes les choses et c'est très
contre-productif aussi bien pour les
policiers que pour les citoyens
par contre nous avons un mode horde
comac quelles que soient les
revendications des policiers c'est que
monsieur castaner doit partir il n'est
pas à sa place
on espère qu'il y aura un remaniement
prochainement il fera partie des gens à
qui on dira au revoir aux états unis top
départ pour la campagne présidentielle
de donald trump
un rendez vous sous tension ce soir son
grand meeting est organisé à tulsa en
oklahoma c'est une ville symbole d'un
des plus importants lynchage
d'afro-américains en 1921
cent mille personnes attendues le
président américain a déjà lancé un
avertissement au potentiel
protestataires dans cette ville
républicaine qui lui est largement
acquise
aucun trouble ne sera toléré a dit
donald trump qui menace également son
ancien conseiller john bolton à deux
jours de la sortie d'un livre à charge
il paiera le prix fort at il déclaré
françois la ville en vert
les polémiques des critiques des
dérapages en tous genres rarement un
président américain à diriger son pays
en suscitant une telle défiance les
attaques viennent régulièrement du
propre camp de donald trump
dernière en date celle de son ancien
conseiller à la sécurité nationale lors
d'un entretien accordé à nbc news john
bolton a ainsi décrit un homme inapte à
présider les états unis
ce commentaire vient ponctuer
l'avalanche d'affirmations embarrassante
contenues dans ses mémoires qui doivent
paraître mardi prochain des révélations
qui alimente un peu plus l'image dans
dirigeants incompétents sur la scène
internationale et surtout prêts à tout
pour se faire réélire
toujours selon john bolton le président
américain aurait ainsi demandé l'aide de
la chine pour satisfaire ses électeurs
agriculteurs en achetant leur stock de
soja et de blé comme à son habitude
donald trump a nié en bloc et contre
attaquer sur twitter le livre de ce
cinglé de john bolton extrêmement
fastidieux new york times est composé de
mensonges et de fausses histoires il a
dit du bien de moi par écrit jusqu'au
jour où je les vire est un imbécile
ennuyant mécontents qui ne voulait qu
aller à la guerre n'a jamais eu la
moindre idée a été ostracisés et
heureusement je t'ai quel idiot mais les
difficultés de donald trump ne s'arrête
pas là sa gestion de la pandémie qui a
fait plus de 118 mille morts aux
etats-unis est vivement critiqué le taux
de chômage a lui explosé pour atteindre
les 13% tandis qu'une vague de colère
contre les brutalités policières s'est
répandue dans plusieurs villes
américaines
enfin donald trump doit aussi composer
avec les décisions de la cour suprême la
plus haute juridiction du pays a
notamment validé les protections légales
accordées par son prédécesseur barack
obama à 700 mille migrants arrivés
mineurs dans le pays
le président américain a une nouvelle
fois dénoncé un acharnement contre sa
politique
ces décisions horrible et politiquement
orientés qui sortent de la cour suprême
sont des coups de fusil au visage des
gens qui sont fiers de se dire
républicain aux conservateurs nous avons
besoin de plus de justice
sinon nous perdrons notre deuxième
amendement et tout le reste
votez trump pour 2020
c'est donc dans un contexte très
défavorable que donald trump va devoir
partir en campagne pour la
présidentielle du 3 novembre prochain
face à lui le candidat démocrate joe
biden prend le large dans les sondages
avec au moins 10 points d'avance il
malgré tout ces vents contraires
donald trump continue de croire en ses
chances le président candidat compte
notamment sur les meetings électoraux
devant des milliers de ses partisans
et ce ne sont pas les risques potentiels
de contamination à grande échelle qui
vont le dissuader de maintenir ces
étapes essentielles dans sa course à la
réélection
les américains qui ont commémoré hier le
155e anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé des milliers de personnes se
sont rassemblées dans le pays comme ils
signé à new york où une marche pour dire
non au racisme a eu lieu une
commémoration sur fond de tensions
raciales après la mort de deux
afro-américains au cours
d'interpellation policière ces dernières
semaines et à washington des
manifestants ont abattu la statue d'un
général sudiste
albert pike c'est son nom c'est un
officier confédérés et écrivain
américain il aurait aussi fait partie du
klu klux klan sa statue a donc été jeté
à terre vous le voyez à l'aide d'une
corde plusieurs dizaines de
contestataires ont décroché ce symbole
du passé et donald trump a dénoncé je
cite une honte pour le pays et il ne
parle pas du général pike bien sûr
écouter
la police de washington ne fait pas son
travail en regardant une statue être
démolies et brûlé ces personnes
devraient être immédiatement arrêtées
une honte pour notre pays
le monde entre dans une nouvelle phase
dangereuse c'est l'avertissement de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé 150
mille nouveaux cas de co vide à
l'échelle de la planète avant-hier un
record sur une seule journée depuis le
début de l'épidémie
le brésil lui franchi le cap du million
de contamination grégoire doucet des
chiffres qui ne cessent de s'accroître
si la vie normale reprend peu à peu ses
droits comme ici à sao paulo
le virus continue de tuer avec plus d'un
million de cas et près de cinquante
mille morts le brésil détient le bilan
le plus meurtrier sur la planète après
les états unis dans l'état de rio de
janeiro ce point de dépistage façon
driving a été installé pour tester les
habitants d'après des statistiques
rapportées par el país brasil
ce territoire est actuellement celui qui
détient le plus haut taux de mortalité
du pays parmi les populations les plus
touchées sur l'ensemble du sol brésilien
figure les communautés autochtones aux
lignes au paille à cannes caciques de la
tribu kayapos et grand défenseur de la
forêt amazonienne est lui-même décédé
ducobu 19 il ya quelques jours
d'autres peuples indigènes s'en sortent
mieux face à la pandémie
mais préfère rester prudent et il est
difficile pour nous d'éviter le contact
avec d'autres personnes
beaucoup de gens passent par cette
frontière mais il donné l'ordre aux gens
de ne pas aller dans d'autres endroits
dans d'autres communautés et de ne pas
recevoir des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur
c'est ainsi que nous vivons sans parler
à personne
[Musique]
il s'agit d'une population indigène qui
n'a aucun cas de kobe 19 il nous
répondons à ces besoins en pédiatrie
gynécologie orthopédie chirurgie
clinique médicale tout ce dont elle a
besoin pour établir un diagnostic et
fournir le meilleur traitement possible
la gestion de la pandémie par jaillir
ball sonar au est vivement critiquée
depuis l'arrivée du virus
le président brésilien est régulièrement
accusé de ne pas avoir pris la juste
mesure de la crise
l'ancien ministre de la santé abonde
dans ce sens ainsi qu'à la tv du fig mag
la société brésilienne a de grandes
difficultés en matière de comportement
en raison de la nature douteuse des
orientations
le ministère de la santé a demandé
renforcé avec les gouverneurs la
nécessité de l'isolément de la distance
le président de la république a dit
exactement le contraire il a démontré le
contraire il a systématiquement briser
ce courant il a fait douter beaucoup de
gens il s'est toujours concentrée sur
l'économie et n'a jamais cherché à
préserver des vies
certains scientifiques redoutent une
sous-estimation des chiffres officiels
en raison du manque de test dans une
population qui compte près de 212
millions d'habitants et c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
je
elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe
c'est à dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant mais
on recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est un père dit d'un
ternie
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins en
france